Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, the final episode, Episode Seven: a new focus on defending Denmark, the war in Ukraine, Greenland and the Arctic.
The story now turns back home.
In recent years, the USA and its allies have again turned their gaze away from promoting peace, democracy, human rights and the rule of law around the world through military actions.
That is due, among other things, to the limited success of the operations in, for example, Iraq, Afghanistan and Libya, where in the long run it did not succeed to achieve the goals of creating peace and setting up democratic governments that support the West.
And not least significant, there is again much greater focus on a solid and effective territorial defence.
That is the ability to defend your own territory against an attack from other countries.
This is due to a number of different circumstances.
Decisive for the wish to strengthen the European NATO countries' territorial defence has been that the relationship between the West and Russia has been marked by more and more conflicts in recent years.
Russia has expressed that it feels its interests are violated, because most of Russia's neighbouring countries in Central and Eastern Europe, which were allied with Russia, the Soviet Union, during the Cold War, have since 1999 been admitted as members of NATO.
Also three countries in the former Soviet Union, Estonia, Latvia and Lithuania, have joined NATO.
Conversely, NATO has emphasised that the countries are free to apply for admission to the defence alliance.
In addition, the Warsaw Pact and the Soviet Union were dissolved, in 1991, with Russia's own acceptance.
The increased tensions have great importance for Denmark's security-policy situation.
That is not least because Denmark is located by the Baltic Sea, which both NATO and Russia regard as an important area of interest.
Russia has, among other things, threatened to attack the three Baltic countries Estonia, Latvia and Lithuania.
And the Danish Defence Intelligence Service assesses, for example, that it is very likely that Russia is behind disturbance of navigation signals, GPS, over the Baltic Sea.
Since 2014, Russia has kept the peninsula of Crimea in Ukraine occupied, and Russia has also sent weapons and soldiers to support pro-Russian rebels' fight to break away parts of eastern Ukraine.
Last but not least, Russia in February 2022 launched an extensive military attack on Ukraine, which has led to war between the Russian and Ukrainian armies and thereby great destruction and sent millions of Ukrainians fleeing.
In response, the West, including Denmark, has supported Ukraine with weapons, training and money to defend itself against the Russian attacks.
In this context, Denmark is one of the countries in the world that have helped Ukraine the most, and especially in relation to the size of Denmark's population.
Among other things, the Danish government decided in 2023 to donate 19 F-16 fighter jets to Ukraine and train pilots from the Ukrainian air force to use the planes.
Further, the West has tried to weaken the Russian economy with extensive economic sanctions, with exclusion of Russian banks from the international payment system SWIFT, a ban on selling a number of goods to Russia, and a decision to stop buying Russian oil.
Many Western companies have withdrawn from Russia.
Another reason for the rearmament is that the USA has been dissatisfied that most European NATO countries let their defence budgets fall quite a lot after the end of the Cold War.
The USA therefore believes that Europeans have left too large a part of the bill for Europe's own security to the USA, which spent far more money on defence.
Therefore, the NATO countries agreed in 2014 that each country should spend two percent of their gross domestic product, the value of a country's total production, on defence.
And the ambitions have grown since.
In June 2025, the target has been raised to five percent.
Denmark has on the one hand been one of the NATO countries that after the Cold War has been most willing to send soldiers to American-led military operations abroad, for example in Afghanistan and Iraq.
But on the other hand, Denmark spent less money on defence.
For example, Denmark's defence budget fell in the period 1990 to 2015 from 2.0 to 1.05 percent of gross domestic product, far below NATO's target of two percent.
And the number of conscripts fell in the same period from about 10,500 to 4,300 a year.
Furthermore, the money for defence was increasingly spent on being able to send forces out on international tasks rather than defending Denmark.
This led to a clear reduction in the number of soldiers, and many of the defence's barracks, naval stations and air stations were closed down.
In addition, US foreign policy seems to be changing.
Among other things because China's power is growing, and the USA is thereby increasingly prioritising countering the competition from China.
This happens, among other things, by moving more investment and more military to Asia and the Pacific and to the USA's own neighbouring area.
It creates uncertainty about the extent to which the USA will continue to take part in the defence of Europe, not least against a possible attack from Russia.
As a result of the war in Ukraine, NATO's increased targets, and the changed priorities in American foreign policy, Denmark and the other European countries have decided that far more money is to be spent on defence in future, so that we get better at defending ourselves in case of an attack.
The Danish defence spending already in 2024 reached over two percent of gross domestic product.
This now applies to all 32 member countries of NATO.
Together, the European NATO countries have increased defence spending from 1.4 percent of gross domestic product in 2014 to about 2.3 percent in 2025.
And very large additional amounts have been set aside in the coming years, which in 2026 are expected to lift Denmark's defence spending to 3.5 percent.
In the same period, US defence spending has fallen from 3.7 to 3.2 percent of GDP.
Thus the difference between the American and the European defence spending, in relation to the size of the economies, has become considerably smaller.
The increased funding is to be used, among other things, to buy more and newer equipment, such as more tanks and fighter jets, as well as underwater torpedoes and advanced defence systems that can shoot down enemy aircraft and missiles from the ground.
In addition, it was decided in 2024 that more soldiers are to be called up, so that the number of conscripts is to be increased to 7,500, from about 5,200 in 2023, and that the service time for most is extended from four to 11 months.
Now to the Realm Community, Greenland and the Arctic in Danish foreign policy.
Greenland, which is part of the Danish Realm Community, had a special importance during the Cold War.
Greenland lies close to both the USA and the then Soviet Union.
In most cases you had to fly over Greenland to take the shortest route between the USA, Europe and the Soviet Union.
The shortest way for rockets in case of war between the USA and Russia, the Soviet Union, also goes over Greenland.
That gave the island great strategic importance in relation to defence cooperation.
In 1951, Denmark and the USA signed an agreement about the USA's military activities in Greenland.
The same year, the Americans began building a large air base at Qaanaaq, Thule, in northern Greenland.
On the base, the USA also built a radar station that could monitor the airspace over Greenland and the waters around Greenland.
The base was central to the air defence of the USA and NATO, and it is still used today by the USA, under the name Pituffik Space Base.
The warmer climate and the melting of the ice in and around Greenland have increased the country's strategic importance in recent years.
In Qaanaaq, near the base, lies the world's northernmost deep-water port, where the water is deep enough for large ships to dock.
And with the warmer climate and the melting of the ice, it is increasingly possible to extract natural resources such as rare earths, uranium, oil, gas and minerals in Greenland that have until now been frozen.
If the sea in the Arctic in future becomes relatively ice-free in summer, it also opens for new, shorter shipping routes via the Arctic Ocean between the world's continents.
The Arctic area has therefore, via Greenland, again come far more into the centre of Danish security policy.
The great powers the USA, Russia and China are all interested in the areas of the Arctic in different ways.
This means the Arctic is increasingly marked by a tense relationship between these countries.
It is both about the countries having an interest in protecting themselves against attack from others, and about the countries having growing economic interests in, for example, mining and transport of goods by ship.
The Danish inspection ship Vædderen patrols off the coast of Greenland.
In recent years, the American president Donald Trump, born 1946, has expressed a wish that Greenland should become part of the USA.
This wish has, however, been rejected by both the Greenlandic and the Danish government.
In the Ilulissat Declaration from 2008, five Arctic states, Denmark and Greenland, Norway, the USA, Canada and Russia, have declared that they agree to cooperate on peaceful relations in the Arctic.
But the declaration was drawn up in a completely different international situation from today, since the relationship between some of the countries has become more tense since 2008.
To strengthen cooperation on sustainable development in the Arctic areas within, among other things, environment, climate, health and shipping, the Arctic Council was established in 1996.
The council has participation by the countries that have territories in the Arctic regions.
That is the USA, Canada, Russia and the five Nordic countries.
In addition, six organisations take part, each representing the indigenous peoples, including the Inuit Circumpolar Council, ICC.
Greenland and the Faroe Islands have a strong independent voice in the Arctic Council.
Greenland has a leading role in the Kingdom's current chairmanship of the Arctic Council, 2025 to 2027.
Here is your recap for Episode Seven, and for Chapter Four.
The war in Ukraine, Russia's attack in February 2022, NATO's targets and the changed US priorities have made territorial defence a priority.
Since 1999, former Soviet-allied countries and the three Baltic states have joined NATO.
Russia has held Crimea since 2014.
Denmark donated 19 F-16 fighter jets in 2023.
NATO agreed in 2014 on two percent of GDP for defence, raised to five percent in June 2025.
Denmark's defence budget fell from 2.0 to 1.05 percent between 1990 and 2015; it was over two percent in 2024, and is expected to reach 3.5 percent in 2026.
All 32 NATO members now spend over two percent.
Conscripts rise to 7,500, and service time from four to 11 months.
In 1951, Denmark and the USA signed an agreement on US military activities in Greenland, and the Thule air base at Qaanaaq was built; it is now called Pituffik Space Base.
Qaanaaq has the world's northernmost deep-water port.
The Ilulissat Declaration dates from 2008, with five Arctic states.
The Arctic Council was established in 1996, and the Kingdom chairs it in 2025 to 2027, with Greenland in a leading role.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Where does the USA have the Thule air base?
Option A: On Bornholm.
Option B: In the Faroe Islands.
Option C: In Greenland.
[DA] Hvor har USA luftbasen Thulebasen?  A: På Bornholm  |  B: På Færøerne  |  C: I Grønland
The answer is C: In Greenland.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: I Grønland
That's the end of this part.
Well done.